just just explain exactly what it is
you'd like the politicians to do
well first of all it's not just a group
of celebrities it is a a group of all
all the sort of pioneering people who've
been working
on getting menopause accepted both in
the workplace and in wider society for
you know donkeys years to be quite
honest we've got doctors we've got all
kinds of different associations the
thing is that in this day and age
celebrities amplify voices that don't
often get heard and the voices of
menopausal women have not been heard
from millennia so first of all we just
want to be in parliament saying
menopause as loudly and emphatically as
we can secondly we're also anticipating
something that's happening later on in
the day when uh speaker with the right
honourable lindsay hall will be
announcing measures for well-being for
women um in terms of parliament actually
recognizing that this is a kind of phase
of life where
excuse me
a lot of women need support and and that
it's a situation that for a very long
time has just left women flandering
you've ended up with one in ten women
leaving the workforce that's a million
women every year because they're trying
to struggle through with symptoms that
dare not speak their name because of the
appalling culture that that has existed
as sort of toxic culture around the
subject of menopause again for way too
long so the fact that we're in
parliament today and presenting to mps
the menopause mandate um is actually a
really historic moment and one that all
women can celebrate because this is a
phase as i say that no woman is going to
escape it happens to 50 of the
population and for all kinds of cultural
social reasons uh that i could bang on
about forever but you probably don't
want me to you know you know
complete a complete oh i'm over of a
different view my reality because
something you said they're really just
really just trying with me they ended up
going into parliament saying the word
menopause menopause menopause over over
and over again it is only in the past
year and a half two years that doing
this job i have noticed as discussing it
as a news topic as a as something that
needs to be looked at needs to be
examined so clearly something has
changed in the recent past
well we're really hoping it has i mean i
made a documentary in 2019 about
menopause and at the time it was
considered absolutely shocking and took
me three years to persuade the bbc to um
to make you know since then obviously
there's been two really strong
campaigning uh documentaries made by
davina for channel four and i do feel
that it is sort of gradually creeping
out there into
society as a whole but the crazy thing
as you just identified is that women
have been going through menopause since
time immemorial and one of the things
that we were so shocked about alice
nelly and i when we wrote cracking the
menopause was the culture of shame
that's developed around it the way it's
been misdiagnosed and misappropriated
and misunderstood unfortunately in no
offense to your own fair sex
but by the very section of the community
of you know that that will never
experience it you know so women have
found themselves you know been cast for
being full of toxic blood and have
leeches applied to various parts of
their anatomy you probably don't want to
talk about on breakfast television and
and and so you know we are finally now
yes it is the last great i would say
it's the last great hurdle i think for
full equality is for what women go
through to be recognized because we
can't afford to lose one in 10 women in
the workplace we can't afford to be
losing a million experienced capable
women every year down to something that
is completely natural and solvable
if if you've got gps who are trained
which they're not enough
just just then just tell us
as much as anything else then and you're
right you're absolutely right the the
reliance share the responsibility has to
rest without you wouldn't have called
you wouldn't have probably a member of
my fair sex if you'd be able to see me
properly your screen must be playing up
this morning mariella but
but what we do need what we do need
as men is is to hear
what it is like if we are not side by
side with someone going through that
process you know our tendency to not
look further than the end of our notes
men need to hear a bit more i think
about
what it feels like to be going through
this
the the very difficult thing about
menopause is well i mean one of the many
difficult things is that it hasn't been
studied enough so to date we have about
50
known symptoms um but the only one that
you know has been widely recognized is
of course the ubiquitous uh
hot flush
which most people deem to be the sign of
menopause i didn't have any i had two
actually and uh they were frankly
one of the most horrendous things i've
ever experienced it felt like someone
put a blow torch to the soles of my feet
and this heat just rose up my body and
you know i started sweating i mean it
was absolutely terrifying and you can't
think of them as anything other than a
hot flash because it doesn't feel like
just getting a bit hot and sweaty at
work but along with that there's all of
these less well-known and in many ways
more debilitating symptoms unless you're
getting a lot of hot flushes a day
anxiety insomnia itchy skin
you know women get to the point where
they feel that they're going crazy and
you that happens to you at a time in
your life when already the pressure of
an aegis society is making you feel
unheard and unwanted and you know so
they go to the doctors a third of women
who go to the doctor presenting
menopausal symptoms
are prescribed antidepressants which is
a disgrace because that makes it really
just compounds the sense that you're
losing your mind when in fact what it is
is your hormones crash they drop
it's going on exactly the opposite
journey that they have when when you're
going through puberty and because of
that huge crash in hormones your body
desperately needs them replaced and so
unless there's a particularly pertinent
medical reason that you can't take hrt
hrt is the solution
it's how you top up your depleted
hormones and it's become incredibly
controversial because it was a terrible
report that came out in 2012 that
basically said that it gave you breast
cancer and that report has been found
since then to be completely flawed to be
inaccurately based on a tiny proportion
of women etc and um you know getting
that out there even is a struggle you've
got in this country about 18 million
women who are 40 and above that means
menopausal women and out of them 550 000
of them are taking hit to help with
their symptoms and the other
what is it 17 and a half million are
struggling through because they think
that the onus is on them which happen so
often to women to just get through it
grit your teeth and actually for a lot
of women that's not possible and it's
tipping them over the edge and they're
leaving the workplace and we want to see
that stop we want to see gps properly
trained we want to see a menopause
specialist in every single gp and
practice in the country and we want free
hrt for women because it should never be
a socio-economic choice and that's what
menopause mandate is campaigning for in
parliament today
well let's see if the government listens
to you mariella foster great to have you
in the program thank you for joining us
thank you